welcome everybody to the newest addition
to the centex fleet of machines the
puget
it's equipped with two rtx 3090s a
terabyte of ram and an intel
w3365 32 core 64 thread cpu my main
purpose for this machine is for
quadruped slash robot dog reinforcement
learning hence all that ram for the
memory buffer and of course the 3090s
which i found to be very good for
machine learning this workstation is
from a company based out of washington
called puget which got its start back in
the year 2000 building systems and has
been doing that ever since before i even
had the machine i was really impressed
by the entire process my experience with
puget started with a phone conversation
about what my current needs were and the
result was a build plan for a machine
specifically suited for those needs from
here every step of the machine's build
process was meticulously logged and i
was notified about what puget was doing
and had already done online i'm pretty
confident that a company that's built
computers for over 20 years can do a
good job of it but i'm also a big
believer in checklists when building and
planning just about anything and seeing
at least the lists that they share with
the customer
it's at least testament in some respect
of their professionalism and their kind
of mindset and approach to this whole
process
so aside from the checklist that you can
view online as your machine is built so
they're literally checking off those
boxes and uploading them uploading the
check marks online that you can see
where they are in the actual process
they also run and share a bunch of
benchmarks for your machine once it is
fully built
finally there's an images tab where they
have images of the completed machine and
even a couple thermal images for idle
and load
and then there are images of the bios
settings should i ever get lost and need
to revisit my starting settings
next i absolutely have to throw some
love towards this case uh i had actually
never heard of fractal design until this
point but the case is made by a company
called fractal design the case is
specifically the define 7 xl i've always
built xl size machines and
i like this case so much that if i build
another one this is almost certainly
going to be the case the case is like
build quality and just feel is
very good very premium and it's very
very customizable
you can do all kinds of stuff with this
case so i can i can see why puget uses
it and comically enough i found videos
from over six years ago from puget and
they were using these fractal design
cases and they really look very similar
to this one so it's clear that fractal
design has just been slowly iterating on
this design so it's pretty cool to see
the evolution of this this case over
time also even in this in this video you
can see there's that custom fan mount
and i imagine that's probably built by
the same person who designed the custom
support bracket for the 30 90s in my
machine
the rtx 3090 card is a 2.5 slot thick
card it's extremely long it's very heavy
it's known to put a lot of pressure on
your pcie slots so it's pretty essential
that these cards are supported in some
way i wouldn't be surprised if a lot of
the issues with 3090s that people are
having are simply because they're not
physically supporting their 30-90 cards
so it's really cool to see from puget
this this sort of custom solution for
the the 30 90s in this machine
getting back to the case and the build
every fan here is a knock to a fan other
than the 30 90 cards and you can
definitely tell this machine is very
quiet even at full load
also of note this case does come with a
fan hub which puget has not used so
theoretically we could even add more
fans here very simply on the topic of
fans and being quiet the two sides top
and front panels all have sound
dampening on them the intake areas at
the front and bottom also have removable
meshing for easy cleaning the main
intake for air in this build is on the
front sides so to speak where we have
these large vents going top to bottom
and the exhaust is out the back the
obvious question at this point is does
it work how are the temperatures the rtx
3090 is a 350 watt tdp card
that's a lot of heat per card and we've
got two of them
i like to do benchmarking with actual
workflows that i use so in this case we
have a gpt medium task running
with a 2048 training batch size per gpu
purely to keep these gpus working hard
first we can see the actual wattage as
reported by nvidia smi something like
about 310 to 315 watts average for gpu
one and more like 295 or so for gpu zero
gpu one is also driving the display
which could describe most of this
difference
next we can see the temperatures for the
same run where we have about 65 degrees
celsius for gpu 0 and about 77 degrees
celsius for gpu 1. the delta here is
mostly described by the physics of heat
where warm air rises so the top gpu is
more likely to be sucking in hot air
from the gpu below it plus it's just
getting heated up by the gpu below it
next let's check out my thermal camera
results first with the casing on the
thermal camera tells me the temperature
in white of the thing i'm directly
pointing at then it also shows in red
the hottest point in the photo and in
green the coolest
somewhat comically here we can see the
hottest point in this photo is actually
the wall behind the machine around the
back of the casing we can see the
hottest point here is essentially where
the displayport cable plugs in i never
really put much thought into how much
heat these cables would be
put through over time but clearly it's a
lot if it's on a gpu that isn't just
simply an accelerator opening up the
side panel here not too much shocking
the gpus are indeed hot and you can see
just how much hotter that top gpu is
next i had been curious for quite some
time to see how the rtx 3090 compared to
the rtx 8000
and also of course to the big daddy a100
the 3090 being an ampere architecture is
and should be faster than the rtx 8000
but i also was curious to see how much
faster on a real world type of problem
so uh using the exact same benchmark
that i used with the a100 and the rtx
8000s which is again just a gpt medium
with a 10 24 batch size per gpu so i do
have some multi gpu examples i will not
be able to compare multi gpu on this
machine because we do not have an nv
link
so
either you want to have one of those x
sxm boards or you want to have an nv
link
if you want to do multi gpu so if you
want to spread um
the you know train the exact same model
across multiple gpus you definitely want
to have the nv link i didn't realize
how
useful the nv link really was until i
actually compared it with these
benchmarks i mean it makes a huge
difference it's like 100 100 faster if
you have an envy link which is pretty
cool
so anyways getting back to this these
are the results so
basically the big thing here is how
quickly do we step so each step is the
same on every machine the question is
how many steps per second essentially
can we take
so as we can see here the dgx a100 so
that a 180 gigabyte card on that dgx
station was doing about 14 steps per
second the rtx 8000 does 5
and the puget's rtx 3090 is doing 6.8 it
looks like so i went ahead and did the
math here
to compare to the rtx 8000 so 6.8 minus
5 1.8 1.8 out of 5 steps so this means
the
uh 3090 is about 36 percent faster than
the rtx 8000
which is uh pretty substantial so it
does suck more power than the rtx 8000
which is somewhat comical uh probably
about 36 percent more power but the main
difference here for me is the actual
cost of the card now unfortunately the
30 90 is
uh challenging to say the least to get a
hold of
but the actual price that was intended
for this card is 1500
the rtx 8000 is a 5500
card so the fact that you can spend such
a tiny fraction and get a more powerful
card is
very um interesting
and the rtx 8000 does have twice as much
vram at 48 gigs per card so we could
also compare it to something like the
titan rtx card which actually is a
smidgen faster than the rtx 8000 card
the difference here i think is the rtx
8000 is clocked down slightly because
it's a server card um just taking a
guess
because it otherwise has i believe the
same number of cuda cores so anyways
pretty interesting results it's again
essentially 36 percent faster than at
least the rtx 8000 or the titan rtx um
they're pretty close the rtx 8000 and
the titan rtx but it is that our titan
rtx i've found to be slightly faster and
clearly the a100 is still the massively
reigning champion
um at still like basically twice as fast
as the rtx 30 90 and three times as fast
as that rtx 8000.
moving forward at least for me
personally i'll be continuing to use
this machine in these lovely rtx 3090s
for reinforcement learning with the
biddle robot dogs so far the machine's
been treating me very well and i've
enjoyed learning more about
reinforcement learning with this project
i'll put a link to that series in the
description if you've not yet seen it
also of course if you're in the market
for getting a pc builds definitely check
out puget systems i'll put a link to
them in the description otherwise you
all know the deal thanks for watching
and i will see you in another video
you